الان معنا في الاستديو هنا العميد الياس
حنان الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه اهلا
بك العميد الياس حنا نبدا بالاوضاع في
مدينه بخموت كيف يمكن ان نقرا هذا الاصرار
من قبل الطرفين الروسي والاوكراني ايضا
على خوض هذه المعركه على الدخول الى
القتال من اجل بخمه رغم الاقرار بصعوبه
الوضع هناك ما اسباب ذلك ايمان لكل من
الفريقين الهدف الاساسي يعني
الجهه الروسيه تريد تحقيق نصر بعد سبعه
ثمانيه اشهر من ليسي شانسك
وسيفري دونات وفي نفس الوقت
تقاتل وليس جيش الروسي هذا الامر يعني ان
الخسائر ستكون على شركه فاجنر من الجهه
الاوكرانيه يريد الرئيس وهذا حدده الرئيس
الاوكراني يريد كسب الوقت مقابل المساحه
استنزاف القوات الروسيه وبالتالي استعداد
للتحضير للهجوم الذي قد يحضر له
اواخر الربيع الهجوم الذي قد يحضر له في
اواخر الربيع في اين في اي المواقع
بالتحديد ليس في ضخمه يعني ليس في مخموت
اصبحت معركه سياسيه وليست معركه عسكريه
ليست ذات قيمه كبيره الا من ضمن الاهداف
التي تحدثنا عنها المرحله القادمه هي
مرحله الاعداد لحرب معينه المنطقه العسكري
والساحه العسكريه تقول انه قد يكون في
خرسون او قد يكون في ميليتوبول من
زابولوجيا لقطع الجسر البري وتهديد شبه
جزيره القرم التي يعتبرها الرئيس بوتين هي
الجوهره في التاجر والمشروع لكن رغ
تاكيدات يعني اكثر من طرف بان
ليباخ مت اهميه رمزيه وليست استراتيجيه
فكيف نقرا يعني هذا او هذه الاستماته
للدخول لهذه المدينه وحمايه هذه المدينه
رغم ما قيل بان ليست لها اي اهميه
استراتيجيه هي ليست لها اهميه استراتيجيه
اصبحت معركه سياسيه ومعركه اراده مع انه
الفريق الاوكراني يخسر نخبه العسكر في هذه
المنطقه من الجهه الروسيه اذا نظرنا الى
الشمال
بخموت وبالتالي جنوبا الى
اوغلي دار هذا الخط هو الخط الاساسي الذي
يعمل عليه جيش الروسي لتثبيت القوات
الاوكرانيه ومنعها من التحضر المعركه
القادمه في الربيع هذه الخساره الاوكرانيه
لنخبه العسكر كما تقول هل يمكن ان تحول
بوصله المعارك الى جبهات اخرى لا سيما
جبهه الجنوب ليس بالضروره لانه النجاح
الاوكراني في المرحله القادمه يعتمد على
ما يليه
العتاد خاصه الدبابات والدفاع والذخيره
الغربيه
كميتها المده سرعه التسليم وتحضير العسكر
من ضمن اليه معينه ترتيب معين ليكون جاهز
عملانيا وبالتالي تحضير المعركه هذا هو سر
النجاح للاوكران عندما يقول بوتين بان هذه
الحرب في اوكرانيا هي مساله وجوديه ماذا
يعني برايك وما الذي يمكن يترتب على ذلك
التصريح استراتيجيا او عسكريا بالمعنى
بالمعنى الاستراتيجي اوكرانيا مهمه
لروسيا كانها دوله عازله منها تاتي
المخاطر على سبيل المثال الهجوم النازي في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
ولكن هي ليست معركه وجوديه الا له بالمعنى
السياسي ولكنها معركه وجوديه بالطبع
لاوكرانيا لانه زوال اوكرانيا يعني زوال
كل الشعب الاوكراني والقياده الاوكرانيه
الخبير الع سكري والاستراتيجي